both the EU and ASEAN have a similar
goal regional integration but their
models couldn't be more different while
the EU has already established
supranational institutions such as the
EU Commission as yawns members would
rather retain their national sovereignty
I think EU is something very unique
which is very different from other types
of regionalism this is a regional
regional institution that agrees with
this new notion where the nation states
has to lose some of its sovereignty in
order to make sure that the cooperation
becomes much closer the integration
become becomes more intense but there
are signs of progress on the integration
front by the end of the year ASEAN
countries want to establish a joint
economic zone that allows free movement
of labour and capital without tariffs
that poses a challenge for the Asian
economies which are at very different
stages of development that's why they're
looking westwards we will be able to our
gain knowledge from EU how it is
narrowing the development gaps between
the countries in the EU but the EU
cannot serve as a blueprint for ASEAN
open political confrontation that's
common to Europe for example is
unacceptable in much of Asia it will be
not good for ASEAN to say that Europeans
are impatient but this is how we see the
Europeans but in Asia particularly in
ASEAN countries we are patient we will
try to find ways to reach the common
goal consensus on important issues and
consensus is one hallmark of a common
cultural identity that's something ASEAN
countries still find hard to define if I
go to Europe and I talk to different
people I think they they see this
identity emerging and they see problems
that all of them as a European have to
deal with in a cien
it is not progressed very well they
haven't started this product of work on
this process of creating this cultural
identity you know within the region
themselves the EU much like ASEAN
started as an economic and political
union getting to a common cultural
identity is a much taller order but it's
one that's necessary to bind regions
together in both continents